hello there welcome to another episode
of Science and Technology q a for kids
and others I think last week we've been
talking about AI it looks like we have a
big overrun of questions about AI here
so
you know I've got something I was
thinking about which is
uh so what's going to happen to
education in the world of of AIS because
it's um
increasingly the case that
um
the uh ai's
just as AIS will be able to do things
for us AIS will get to know us better
and they'll get to be quite to be better
at knowing what to explain to us so that
we understand things
that's one thing the other thing is in
most settings right now people
are in classrooms where there's one
teacher and there's a whole bunch of
students
the
when one's able to interact with a good
AI the AI will be able to give on sort
of personalized instruction it's kind of
like being a
a one-on-one student and teacher and
that will accelerate the rate at which
people can learn things as the AIS learn
more about us humans and how we learn
and how a specific human learns the AI
is going to be better at saying this is
the one thing I need to tell you right
now this is what you're confused about
let me explain that one particular thing
to you and so I think what's going to
happen is that the speed at which we
humans can learn things is going to
increase I don't know how much five
times maybe I'm not sure
um the only will probably happen is you
know something and it kind of gradually
decays you kind of forget the details
and then
it probably will be the case that sort
of the refresher is also aiable and
it'll be the case that you can uh you
know when you start saying well I need
to remember about this and the AI can
ask you a couple of questions and then
it realizes you've forgotten that part
and it's going to feed you back that
part and then that helps jog your memory
however that works we don't know how
that works for humans exactly maybe
we'll learn a bit how it works from from
looking at AIS
um actually there's one thing to point
out that's interesting about about
Chachi BT and the large language models
llms and so on
is that the types of mistakes they make
and the types of things they can do are
very human
and you know it's something where we
haven't really had a theory of why do
people sort of not manage to solve that
math problem quite correctly how do
these people get a little bit confused
about this or that
probably by studying llms we'll be able
to get an idea of how those human
mistakes are getting made and
potentially you know what you tell the
human at what moment you should tell the
human to do something in order to avoid
the mistake
you know there are many fields in which
people have gradually learned how to get
humans to not make mistakes for example
there were plenty of fields in which
there's checklists are an important
thing kind of like did you remember
those 10 things you're supposed to do
before you fly the airplane off
um well it's more than 10 for airplanes
but but um
the uh uh you know and this idea of
let's have a checklist and you
specifically go through this this this
this this this checking it off that's
kind of a mechanism for preventing one
making mistakes I I know in my efforts
uh programming I've done a lot of
programming in my life and one of the
things I learned early on was the types
of mistakes that I make and uh so I kind
of so gradually I got to be well I know
what type of mistake I make so let me be
careful when I've written this piece of
code let me be careful to check it for
that type of mistake I'll say another
thing when I write text my absolutely
most common mistake is leaving words out
and um I think that um the uh but so
given that I know that when I'm reading
through what I've written and so on I'm
I'm alert for the fact that oh it might
have a word missed out including you
know the word not and things like this
so I think that's the kind of thing
where
as we kind of uh you know learning the
types of mistakes we make is something
that is a very doable thing for AIS and
being able to see this particular llm
makes this particular kind of mistake I
don't think any of the llms will make
the living words out mistake uh the of
the the current ones at least I'm kind
of wondering if you overclock it so that
you're insisting the Priestess tokens at
a very rapid rate maybe you can get it
to leave leave words out and maybe
that's maybe that's my brain's problem
so to speak when I write text and leave
words out I'm not sure
so uh in any case let's see
there are a bunch of questions here my
gosh lots and lots of things
um
uh
okay lots of interesting questions
um
there's a question here
about the future of jobs
uh when we're able to provide basic
things to everyone with a machine like
you know Food Water Shelter and so on at
that point will jobs be obsolete or not
this is a long running story of History
it's one is enough enough
that is there comes a time when uh you
know in some developed country or
whatever else
um and some at least some parts of the
country it's like getting the the food
you need to eat is not a big problem or
getting you know shelter is not a big
problem
uh at earlier times or in different
places maybe that is still a problem but
um uh you know for some large class of
people it's not a problem
and then the question is well then just
sit back and do nothing then
well it's not the way our species seems
to be built the better or worse it's
like people always want to do more you
know when when if you can get the basics
taken care of for many people at least
it's kind of like there's more stuff
that one wants to do or that or that in
a sense needs to be done I mean it's
kind of like
you know a good example is houses
if you say uh you know what was a house
like 300 years ago okay it had walls it
had some maybe some windows it had you
know it had rooms Etc et cetera et
cetera
but now if you look at a house what's in
its walls it's got all kinds of stuff
it's got all the electrical wiring it's
got Plumbing it's got network cables
it's got all kinds of stuff
and the expectations for what a house
should consist of have considerably
increased and which is why for example
construction even though many things can
be pre-manufactured many things are more
automatic have more machines and so on
still takes uh you know a certain a
significant amount of time
and um
I think that's the thing that happens
all over the place is expectations go up
it's not enough just to have sort of
basic food to eat you know if you're
going to eat
I don't know
some you know bread and something or
other every day oh that's not enough you
have to have something more than that
and that tends to be the thing that I
think as a driver for uh you know the
the idea that you don't get even if you
can automate to a some to some level
that automation then provides you the
possibility of doing more things and
then there's more things for people to
do and I think what can also happen is
once something has been automated then
sort of more of it happens and that can
generate issues that necessarily require
people to deal with them at least until
one has understood those things well
enough that one can then automate to the
next level so I think um uh it won't be
the case the jobs will be obsolete I
think one thing that you do see in
economies you see it even in today's
world would you see it also historically
is as economies get more developed the
number of different kinds of jobs that
get done dramatically increases like in
the U.S 150 years ago the majority of
jobs were agricultural farming but
nowadays the pie chart of what jobs
people do is pretty finely sliced into
all kinds of different categories and I
think that's a thing that one will tend
to see as more is automated more
different things there are more
different things that people can do and
and choose to do and so on and so
I also suspect and this is a different
point about uh uh sort of what jobs
people do and do they only do one job or
do they do multiple kinds of things I I
suspect there will be more and more of
people are not just doing this they're
also doing that I mean for myself you
know I have for a long time you know run
a tech company for 36 years now you know
I also try and do basic science I also
try and do some educational kinds of
things
um I also do stuff about history and so
on you know I'm a sort of in a sense I
have uh you know I've chosen to have the
equivalent of of multiple careers so to
speak uh all mush together and they have
many interactions between them but but
they're really different kinds of
activities and I think that that will be
something uh you know I know many people
who are likewise and I think that's a
thing that will be increasingly common
um you know it always used to be the
case people would have you know they
would have their work they would have
their hobby
um I think there's there's going to be
more of a uh you know Hobbies become
work and work becomes you know if one's
lucky one's doing work that one enjoys
as much as one would a hobby so to speak
um but I think when it comes you know we
can see in in the world today uh you
know people who were like oh I play
video games for fun well actually I'm
making a living as a you know Esports uh
you know or a a a live streamer of um of
of playing video games and so on so a
lot of these things that were just hobby
become less uh sort of uh less hobbyist
um and become sort of secondary jobs so
to speak so I think the landscape of of
what people do will I my guess is that
one of the things is they'll be more
fragmented there are more different
categories there are more different an
individual person might do more
different kinds of things but they might
say where any one of them could have
been a whole job before but now it's
just part of uh you know part of the
portfolio of things people do
um
let's see
uh
Dr verm here is asking are we about to
reach a post-truth world due to AI
enabled misinformation how do we combat
this
you know
it's always a complicated thing because
it is you know it was the case that
writing something publishing it in a
newspaper and so on it's all a lot of
effort you know the newspaper you know
you you're you're printing something in
a newspaper okay you know I've even seen
these giant printing presses for
newspapers and and um they're you know
it's it's a big production it's like it
costs a lot of money you you switch on
the presses you know the big streams of
paper go through and you're printing
printing things for newspapers and then
you're delivering the newspapers to
places and so on it's all a lot of
effort and
you know it has to be worth something to
go to all that effort it's um if you
write some completely uninteresting you
know nonsense story that nobody cares
about you're not going to go to the
trouble of printing it Distributing the
newspapers doing all those kinds of
things but when one's dealing with the
web and so on the cost of putting some
content out there has gone down to
basically nothing and so what was kind
of this big constraint that you know
nobody nobody bothers to publish a book
a newspaper whatever else that nobody's
going to read or that's complete
nonsense or whatever you know maybe
sometimes it'll be nonsense but highly
entertaining and lots of people will
read it that's a different that's a
different Dynamic but the idea that
there's kind of a um
uh the the sort of a threshold that had
to be passed for information to get out
there that threshold is now zero
that still there has been at least some
threshold which is somebody's got to
actually write that whole essay about uh
you know how the uh um you know how a
llama escaped from the local zoo and and
started um uh you know eating its way
through whatever you know somebody's got
to write that piece well except now they
don't because with large language models
and so on the the it's rather easy to
say you know write a story about how a
llama escaped from a zoo right a story
about how alarm escape from this
particular Zoo feeding a few facts about
the zoo and you've got a completely
realistic story about a llama escaping
from a zoo and hopping over fences and
whatever llamas do
um
it's uh and then the problem is that the
cost of producing that is exceptionally
low you put it out on the web where the
cost of distribution is exceptionally
low and you've got a story that may have
absolutely nothing to do with anything
um now you know you say well that story
about the Llama it's misinformation it's
there wasn't any llama it didn't do that
you know there was no llama that um uh
that kind of did a you know jumped in
the air and did a backflip type thing or
whatever it is
um the uh uh but yet it was written as a
beautiful essay and it was put out on
the web and it's like this is all you
know nonsense
well of course you know you have to
realize that there's fiction is a
perfectly valid form of of uh of human
expression and you could have a lovely
story about the Llama that did this and
you know learned to be a gymnastic llama
or whatever else
um and uh uh you know that's a valid
thing now you might say identify this is
a work of fiction you know I was I was
just uh using chat gbt yesterday asking
it to
um write something and it uh it now
makes a big effort to say of course this
isn't real this is a work of fiction and
satire and then it goes and writes the
thing
um so it's uh
it's beginning to try to have some
awareness of that type of issue but
that's that's one thing to say another
thing to say is when one even defines
you know what's misinformation what's
true what's not true
Etc
um
you know
it's uh it's often very hard to know
there are some domains like well take
mathematics for example you think you
know what's true what's not true two
plus two equals four two plus two
doesn't equal five
okay but
there is
a you know does two plus one equal three
or does two plus one equals zero or one
well you say how could two plus two two
plus one equal one
well
if you happen to be working in mod 2
arithmetic kind of clock arithmetic
where you're where zero is it where two
is equivalent to zero then two plus one
equals a equals one
and but you say but that's not what I
meant by plus and so on well it gets a
little bit more complicated even in an
area like mathematics and and it's a a
much deeper issue in mathematics that
there can be questions that uh given any
fixed set of sort of axioms that Define
mathematics you can end up with
questions where you can't decide whether
they're true or not based on those
axioms so even an area as as firmly kind
of tied down as mathematics the question
of what's true is actually a bit
complicated
and when it comes to things about the
world
um it's uh uh you know it's it's vastly
complicated you know for example
um I don't know
well here's a good one the Llama likes
to eat peanuts
okay
really I mean you have a llama you
handed a pink some peanuts the Llama
grabs the peanuts and eats them then it
makes a funny face and indicating that
it really didn't like the taste of those
okay the Llama like eating the peanuts
did not like eating the peanuts another
llama might you know look at the peanuts
and brush them aside or whatever it is
um you know the question of does the
Llama like eating peanuts is a
complicated one and obviously you can
have versions of that when it comes to
you know people and opinions about
people oh so and so uh you know is a is
a terrible person in this way oh so and
so but actually in this way they're not
a terrible person so it gets very
complicated to know an unusually human
language is a very inexact way to kind
of state what's true and what's not so
to speak
one of the only places where we really
have really pretty tied down notion of
something analogous to truth is in
computational language if you write a
piece of Orphan language code and it
says this then you run it and it does
the thing it is defined to do when it is
run you know the function plus the
movement language does a particular
thing it's not kind of a an everyday
language plus where it could mean this
it could mean that and so on
so I think this this question of um of
kind of what as I say in the case of um
uh that there are certain kinds of
things which get very sort of
computational but you can actually tie
down the notion of does this equal that
and so on but when it comes to human
language and when it comes to even
things like mathematics the question of
sort of what's ultimately true is a
pretty complicated question
and so you know there are cases in which
somebody and and this whole issue of
what is intended to be fact what is
intended to be fiction what is intended
to be and one of the things that's been
tricky and I must say I'm not a big fan
of is is the idea and it's something you
know during the pandemic for example
it's something that was often discussed
you know governments for example or
other organizations telling people you
know you know emphasizing this thing
it's really dangerous to do this or it's
really whatever to do that and you could
say say it's really dangerous to do x
what does that actually mean you know
there's some probability that you'll get
this thing that will happen based on a
thousand samples and this and that and
the other but sometimes there was kind
of an idea that you tell people it's
really dangerous then they won't do it
and that's good in general for some
reason and you know this idea that that
what you say the words you use to
describe things can be uh you know
you'll use the it's really dangerous
as opposed to there's a probability of
one in seven that you will get you know
some you know you'll get sicker or
something if you do this you know saying
it's really dangerous to do it versus
there's a probability of one in seven
that this will happen is a matter of you
know they might both mean the same thing
to some people it's really dangerous to
do this means there's a one in seven
chance that you'll get really sick
um would be you know that's a perfect
translation between those things but to
other people it's really dangerous to
they'll hear that as something very
different from there's a probability one
and seven to do this or that thing and I
think there was a you know there's a
certain uh it's complicated to say is it
misinformation to say it's really
dangerous to do this when the
probability is one in seven some people
might say oh well it depends on you know
what the end point is how sick you're
gonna get and if it even if it's one in
fifty and you get really sick you might
still say it's real really dangerous to
do X you know if the chances one in 50
million but there's a chance that you
know something terrible happens to you
if you do it most people probably say it
would not say it's valid sort of to say
it's really dangerous to do X
but so I think it's really difficult to
have a a definition of misinformation so
to speak and I think one of the things
that's sort of interesting is that in
today's world with llms and so on this
question of
um uh sort of making these judgment
calls about whether it's a good eye
whether something is is okay or not
it's kind of going to be an interesting
llm meets llm story because for example
if you if you host a website and you say
I don't want any pictures on this
website that depict anything bad
happening to animals let's say
well you can um
uh and and that's your your terms of
service so to speak question is how do
you decide that well you could have some
team of people and they look at all
these pictures and they say this cat
doesn't look very happy in this picture
whatever else it is
um or you could have a uh an AI system
that basically has where you give it a
textual prompt that says you know uh
that all animals and all depicting all
these pictures have to look happy or
whatever it is and it will based on the
training that it's had based on based on
the average of having seen lots of
pictures on the web and descriptions of
those pictures which said you know happy
cat whatever it said unhappy cat
whatever else it was based on all of
that kind of training data then the AI
will be able to give some conclusion
about is this picture that you're
feeding in that you want to put on this
website is it okay or not and I think
that's something we're going to
increasingly see is kind of these
judgment calls particularly when it
comes to you know is this an okay thing
to post on a social network is it not
those those judgment calls will be made
by llm AI like systems and uh you know I
think that's a it's a it's a funny
situation because the
you might say if if it was the case that
the decision was made just based on the
words that were used
if you were never able to use the word
uh bad
okay then people will find ways if that
was the if it's a very coarse Criterion
like that no no post will ever let you
have the word bad in it
um okay then people will say uh you know
I'm they'll say you know uh backwards
dab or something they'll find a way just
to to you know to run around it so that
the people who are reading it can
perfectly well understand what they
meant before but what's tricky with with
something like an llam is that you're
kind of up against a kind of
computational barrier because people
don't know yet maybe we'll discover a
little bit how to do this how to game an
llab I mean people don't know it's kind
of related to the sort of emerging field
of prompt engineering of you know what
do you tell in llm for example we've had
this issue we now have this wolfen
plugin for chat GPT and we need to be
able to tell it uh you know in if the
you know send this kind of input to this
piece of our plugin send that kind of
input to that piece of our plugin you
know clean up the input that you're
going to feed to our plugin and this or
that way and you know we try putting
capital letters we try putting stars
around on things in the in the textual
prompt and the llm sometimes pays
attention and sometimes doesn't and you
know in our particular case we solve
that technologically by by having sort
of a catcher for what the llm sends that
tries to clean up the mistakes that it
makes but there's a question of well
well is there a science of really
getting the llm to do what you want I
mean it kind of reminds me of if you are
managing people and you really want the
people to do what you want what do you
tell them I don't think I know the
answer even though I've been doing
management for what 40 years or
something more than 40 years now
um I don't think I could tell you the
ultimate this is the exact thing you
tell people to get them to do exactly
what what you want them to do so to
speak
um you know it's it's sort of still an
art form and whether it will whether
there'll be some kind of yes you can
just lock the llm and to do this I'm not
sure but I think this the idea of this
kind of um rather than saying although
these bad words don't don't use those
bad words and that's and it's a very
sort of coarse way where you can always
sort of walk around the bad word type
thing uh if it's kind of you're doing
this thing and it's being graded it's
being rated by it's being decided by an
llam I think it's not going to be so
easy to game and it will do something
which seems to be a fairly human job and
sometimes one will say just as one does
with humans oh that person goofed they
should have agreed that this was okay or
they you know why did they say it wasn't
okay they made a mistake
Etc et cetera et cetera and you'll say
that about the llms as well
um but I think it will be you know that
will be a a common thing so then
you could apply that to sort of the
misinformation story you could ask an
alarm you could say on this site we
won't allow any misinformation okay what
does that mean well the llm can go and
try and decide is this misinformation
it's got It's looks at the web it's got
a lot of things which say which are
tagged as this is misinformation so it
probably has some idea what
misinformation what people think of as
misinformation and uh so you know it
will have a it will have a Fighting
Chance of doing something reasonable
there of course it won't always catch it
and um but I think that's um
um
that's the thing one will see now the
the thing that I'm I'm you know is is
absolutely a thing one we'll see is uh
just tons of of material written put out
there on the web where
um and elsewhere uh where it was written
by an llam it may or may not have
anything to do with anything
um it was just the llm was just told
write something that goes along these
lines and now it's easier to do that
writing so I think it's it's um uh the
um
that's that's kind of uh
um and and you know was it written by an
llm was it not written by an llm you
know at this point us humans have some
sense of you know this is what chat GPT
typically writes but it doesn't need to
be that way and I'm quite certain that
there will be llms that will kind of
evade any kind of wizard in LM or was it
a human type type question
I think that's one shouldn't count on
the fact that unless the the the AI
chooses to declare itself as I am an AI
or unless it's really burnt deep into
the sort of uh psyches the the of the AI
that I'm always going to explain that
I'm an AI I don't think one will be able
to tell
um and this is the thing you know back
in 1950 When Alan Turing one of sort of
pioneers of computing uh invented this
Turing test which was this kind of a
notion of you know when do we know we
have true artificial intelligence well
you you know have a um well I think he
had a a teletype I think was what he was
using but but we could modernize that
you know you're you're just typing to
something and you're typing text
messages to something can you tell if
the thing at the other end of your text
messaging stream is a human or an AI and
his sort of test for what we'll know we
have genuine AI is when you can't tell
and I'm sure we've got to that point now
in the last few months
so
anyway harazos
since today chat GPT can only reproduce
written human reasoning will it ever be
possible for chat gbt to be better than
humans one day I think the answer is yes
there will be things that it will do
better than humans I mean they're
already the thing that I think it's
pretty good at is
and implicitly noticing patterns across
large amounts of information so it's
pretty good making analogies you know
um you know hand is to finger as foot is
to toe or whatever but much grander
analogies and some of the things that
one's interested in in science and other
places are I know that pattern I've seen
something like this before this thing
that I'm trying to solve in physics is
just like this thing that I solved
before in chemistry let's say
um and for a human that can be something
of a stretch to notice that analogy you
have to understand something about both
of those fields for the AI it's it's got
an you know it's it's ingested knowledge
about that's ingested of this text about
those different fields and it's going to
notice you know gosh there's this
analogy here between economics and uh I
don't know
um some area of mathematics or something
or physics let's say and because very
few humans knew both of those fields
they were not able to make such an
analogy I mean I have to say this is one
of these things where I feel a little
bit um there's things I have to figure
out in science quickly because otherwise
I don't get to figure them out it'll
just be an AI that figures them out
because for somebody like me I'm
interested in a lot of different fields
and I've learned a fair amount about a
lot of different fields and so I've been
lucky enough to be able to make some of
those sort of grand analogies between
very different fields that people are
not easily able to make usually because
they just don't know you know the two
the two ends of that analogy I think AIS
will will routinely be able to make some
of those things and they'll seem very
sort of superhumanly smart but it's I
think it's it's more because they are
broader than because they are deeper
um and I think that's that's something
we will probably see
um I think that in terms of uh the
access that AIS have to deep computation
I mean an ally them is really just uh
even though it's very useful and
impressive what it's doing is it's sort
of taking some stream of words and it's
saying you know how would I continue the
stream of words based on what's typical
about what's found in the web and on
books and things like that and and that
process of how would I typically
continue it can be very can seem very
sophisticated us it involves lots of
reasoning because well the reason it
seems like it involves reasoning is the
same reason that that was Helen sort of
logic was deduced from text it's like
there are these patterns of if the text
says this then it's going to say this
and those patterns you see over and over
again if it's it says this then it's
going to say this that is the structure
of certain kinds of reasoning and it's
able to kind of lift that structure from
one place to another
that's kind of the nature of the way
that it does generalization
um
and so that means it can it can apply
quotes reasoning because it's seen this
pattern of this implies that in lots and
lots of different cases so it's going to
lift that and apply it in some other
place
um
I think the thing that is really
interesting is the sort of deep
computation the kind of computation that
was discovered in the last 50 years
which you know that I've spent lots of
effort on of of being able to really
compute things about the world where
you're running lots of computation steps
to figure out things about the world to
work out things about nature to work out
things about the mathematical world and
so on that's not the kind of thing that
a large language model can do it's a
much shallower kind of computation
that's just sort of trying to match up
um what it's otherwise seen as text on
the on the web and so on and so the
merger of those two things being able to
take that kind of thing that is a good
match for us humans with with human
language and so on and being able to
connect it to kind of the depth of
computation then in the last 50 years
we've realized it's possible that's
really powerful and that's the thing
that this plugin for for chat EBT that
we built connecting to our kind of
computational system that's what that
enables and I think the thing that's
going to happen which is pretty
interesting is you know a thing that
I've done for decades now is the idea of
computation and making it accessible to
as many people as possible that's sort
of the the thing I've been trying to do
and that's I've done that by creating
this kind of computational language that
expresses things that we think about in
computational terms done that in Wolf
now so for example where you can type a
small piece of natural language and just
get a computational result out
um but we've now got a much broader
version of that with llms we can take a
much more sophisticated set of
instructions so to speak and expect to
turn that into our woven language
computational language
and that's really powerful because then
you know just from thinking about things
in terms of natural language you're
creating this computational language
that lend that Len that's a computer go
off and really you know run run what a
computer can run so to speak and figure
out and make use of what's possible in
the computational universe so to speak
to figure out a lot of things and then
can bring it back and can express it in
natural language and so on so we finally
got the ability you know we've had in
the past we've had sort of there's the
programmer thing there's the Computing
thing and then there's the talking about
things in natural language those two
things are finally merging and that
gives just a you know sort of everybody
access to much deeper computation
something we achieved as a dozen years
ago with wolf malpha for certain kinds
of knowledge and certain kinds of quick
questions where you're just saying I
want to know the answer to this question
well if malva can do that if you want to
say I want to create a program that is
going to run a thousand times to do this
particular thing for this thing that's
not what Wolfram Alpha is set up to do
but now with llms plus the technology we
have for connecting it to both language
you can do that and that's really
something I think exciting because it
kind of opens up the sort of power of of
computation the power of this kind of
knowledge-based computation that we have
in woven language and so on
um to to everybody and um it's you know
people have been worried that oh they're
the people who learn you know techy
stuff and and programming and so on and
the people who don't and but you know
there's a lot of power that comes from
the notion of computation and that's
sort of always you know that has in the
past been kind of been kind of separated
off from people who didn't learn sort of
how to talk to their computers but now
we've gotten much closer to where you
don't really have to learn that just
like in modern Alpha there's no
documentation for us now but you don't
you just type what you want to type and
it will answer questions well now you're
at the point where you can just type
what you want to type and you can make a
piece of computational language code
that you can then put together in
building blocks to build up some
sophisticated to to achieve what you
want to achieve computationally I will
say there's one kind of footnote to that
which is you kind of got to know when
you build up a big tower of
computational capabilities you've kind
of got to know that all the bricks you
put down in the tower are actually kind
of correctly shaped bricks you didn't
start putting foundations down and you
know wind up with the leading Tower of
Pisa because your first few bricks were
were misshapen so to speak relative to
what you thought they were and so I
think that's a place where our
computational language is really
important because it is a language that
is intended for humans to read it's not
like sort of typical programming
languages which are intended just for a
computer to read it's a language
intended for humans to read and so what
you can expect to do now is you tell
your 11 something in natural language it
writes well from language code you read
that code potentially you might just see
whether it does does the obviously right
thing but if you're at all uncertain
about it or you can't quite tell what it
does you read the code and that's
something well there's some learning to
in in how you read that code it's not so
difficult to learn that
and then you say yes it's doing the
right thing and then you start building
this giant Tower and it doesn't lean so
to speak
so let's see
uh
okay ritc asks how can AI through the
lens of this concept of computational
irreducibility that I uh talk about a
lot navigate the landscape of possible
rule sets and Achieve true intelligence
mirror in the complexity of our universe
it's a very interesting question and I
think the answer is it can't
the what an llm does
is it works a bit like out the way our
brains work with neural Nets and so on
and it does things that are very similar
to what we humans do
we humans are not able to go out into
the physical world and immediately say
this is how everything in physics is
going to work we're not set up that way
we're set up so that we can answer
questions quickly about things that are
common in our world we've kind of
evolved through biological evolution Etc
et cetera et cetera and and we've also
chosen to set our world up to be one
where the kinds of things that we're
able to do with our brains with the
neural Nets in our brains and so on the
kinds of things that we're able to do
are ones that uh that we've set up our
world to be the things that we need to
be able to do you know we could have set
things up so that we're continually
confronted with Incredible complexity
and Randomness and so on but we don't we
we choose I mean like like for example
we choose to make our roads be things we
just drive the car down the road we
could have set up roads to be these
complicated things where you know you
had cars with legs and you had to walk
on this you know on this I don't know
I'm thinking of lily pads for a for a
for a frog or something but you know
where you have to walk on this Paving
stone that paving's that stone and so on
and it's very difficult to get from one
you know from one place to another you
have to carefully choose where you put
your your legs
um but we don't we we set up our world
to have roads where you just drive
straight down there in your car or
whatever else it is
um and so it's something where we've
chosen to build our world so that we can
navigate it with the apparatus that we
have in our brains and we also we choose
to not consider those parts of the
physical world we don't live in places
so to speak where where it's very hard
to navigate what's going on we don't um
um and uh so
there are things that we can do
and we set up our world to be a place
where we can you know do the things we
can do so to speak if you say well
what's out there in principle
well what's out there in principle is a
lot of incredible complexity lots of
computational processes that are
irreducible in the sense that you can't
predict what they're going to do
but those are things that we as humans
tend to avoid and our AIS sort of
modeled on us will have the same issues
with those kinds of things you won't
what what you might be able to do is to
say uh for an AI you could say here's
this computational system it's really
complicated
Etc and the AI will will kind of Channel
us humans and they'll say well I think a
human would say this or that about it in
the abstract it's not going to have
something vastly beyond what humans can
say now it's a little bit of a few sort
of footnotes to that comment
so you know if you look at the course of
human intellectual history we've
gradually learned how to talk about more
and more kinds of things we've learned
new ideas New Concepts and so on that
gradually allows us to expand the domain
of computational things that we can talk
about
but one thing to realize is if we expand
to some new domain we can now talk about
let's say fractal patterns well the the
fact that I can talk about them is
because I got a word fractal patterns we
and we have some sort of uh common
understanding of what that word might
mean if you just go out as a solo person
and you say and I've done this I have to
say you go out into a sort of
computational Universe of possible
programs you find all these programs you
have a little idea in your mind of how
these programs work but you don't have a
way to describe it you don't have sort
of a narrative you can tell about it
it's it's a It's Kind of a Funny
situation because you don't really have
that's not a place where you can sort of
talk about what you've seen because you
have no words to describe it you have no
way to communicate what you've seen
so
what I think tends to happen is we
humans sort of as a as a collective
Society or something we gradually move
further out in the domain that we can
understand and we sort of build up a
language a narrative for how we describe
those things and we could tell it to
other humans and we're all sort of
together moving outwards in this in this
domain of things we can understand
now in AI it could do that too and it
could be like happily telling its other
AIS what's going on but unless it can
teach that to us humans unless it gets a
bunch of humans involved as well then
it's it's in a sense it's just going out
and it's a little bit like that
computational system that it's studying
it's just something it's doing some
complicated computation we as humans
can't tell what it's doing it's it's not
it hasn't successfully kind of uh
expanded its domain in a way that we
humans are connected to and care about
so I think that's sort of the the issue
is that it has to not only kind of be
able to be looking at things that are
sort of further out in this domain of
computation it also has to have invented
for us and taught us a language for how
to talk about those things and perhaps
an interesting thing to try to
explicitly do that and to have the AI
sort of come up with a language and then
it's question of okay I've got to you
know sit still long enough to actually
learn that language so I can kind of
ingest that get it into my mind
um so that I can uh so so it becomes
something meaningful to me as opposed to
something well yes the AI is doing it
and it's a lot of bits inside the
computer that are flapping around in
this or that way but it doesn't really
mean anything to me it doesn't really
have doesn't really connect with me
um
as we do ask well we see more of the
phenomenon where AI contributes to the
fundamentals of science
um
we haven't so much seen that yet
I mean there have been sort of AI like
techniques
for quite a long time one of them is
automated theorem proving being able to
take a mathematical theorem and use the
axioms of mathematics to try and figure
out can you make can you use those
axioms to to construct the sort of path
that represents a proof of the theorem I
believe that the only time that an
unexpected Discovery has been made by
automated theorem proving was something
I discovered 23 years ago now about the
minimum Axiom system for Boolean algebra
um most of the time that technique of
automated improving has only really been
used to confirm things that people
already thought were true it's actually
surprisingly rare that sort of I mean
and again I myself have done a bunch of
work along these lines of using what
amounts to AI to discover unexpected
things in science now one of the things
to say about that and it relates to what
I was just saying before is that if you
just see okay you've got this weird
phenomenon you can generated on the
computer
you don't have a way to talk about that
phenomena it's just this weird
phenomenon you've never seen it before
it's just a weird phenomenon and until
you have a conceptual framework until
you have a way to talk about that to
kind of put it in a a framework where it
fits in with other things you won't tend
to think of that as being progress in
science you'll just say this is this
weird random phenomenon that isn't
really connected to anything else the
the progress of science tends to be
making this sort of broad connection
where you can have a narrative that lots
of people understand that you can sort
of you know pull into your mind so to
speak that represents that that piece of
progress
so
I think that's one thing to say another
thing to say is when it comes to llms
themselves there is science to be done
about how they work there's a lot of
questions about things that are
empirically observed and why is that
true things about how big the llm has to
be compared to how much it's learning
Etc et cetera et cetera
um that's something I've been
encouraging some science as physicists
particularly recently to study this
because I think that that's probably it
probably is figurable out why these
kinds of principles exist
um but that isn't known and I think
there's a lot of kind of science to be
worked out about kind of why the um how
uh the the uh kind of how the how the
llm successfully puts together the
language and the way that it puts it
together there's there's facts about
language people have tried to make a
sort of Science of how language Works
Linguistics is sort of a science and how
language Works
um they haven't been terribly successful
a few things can be said a few you know
most languages seem to have nouns and
verbs and adjectives and things those
are categories that seem to be fairly
robust across different languages there
are aspects of the way that um you make
sort of sub Clauses and sentences and so
on that's in Blue Valley universe so but
I would say as a whole I would argue
that um uh sort of the science of
linguistics of saying why are languages
the way they are uh for for us humans
and what sort of global features are
there in those languages hasn't been
particularly successful I think the
success of the alarms is showing us
there is a way to do that stuff we just
didn't do it quite right yet and uh
that's a place where I think the AIS
will contribute by the very nature of
them working to an understanding to a
better understanding for us of a
phenomenon like like human language and
so on
let's see uh
Satoshi is asking what do I think about
AI alignment and the existential risk of
AI
well okay let me explain what that means
first of all you've got an AI it's doing
what it does the question is is what
it's generally doing aligned with what
we humans want it to do
like for example you've got an AI and
it's supposedly uh you know picking
content for some internet site
and we say is it doing that in a way
that and it's figured out that you know
it puts this kind of content on and more
people will click on it and things like
this is it doing it in a way that is
aligned with our overall objectives as a
civilization or whatever you know how
does that work
well the first question is well what are
our overall objectives as a civilization
you know for example one objective that
we probably mostly agree on is we don't
want to go extinct
um and so you know aligning AIS so AIS
don't make us go extinct is probably
something we'd all agree about probably
um what it takes to get there the the
the the more minor steps that's quite
challenging
and you know you can ask well what do
you want to generally say that AIS
should do let me give you an example a
thing you might very well say is I want
ai's let's say an AI is owned by
somebody it's on a computer the computer
is owned by somebody that's software is
owned by somebody and so on you might
say I want that AI to do whatever its
owner tells it to do make it do it
seems like a reasonable thing we say but
wait a minute if the owner tells it to
you know do some terrible thing in the
world surely you want the AI to say no
no I'm not going to do that it's just
like if you have you know a self-driving
car or a car with a bunch of Automation
and you say I want to go faster faster
faster and the car knows it's a 30 mile
an hour speed limit Zone does it go to
35 miles an hour or 40 miles an hour or
whatever or does it say no no no not
going to do that you know it's a 30 mile
an hour speed limit I'm just going to
stay to that
complicated question
you know there are cases in which you'd
say well gosh if you couldn't do that
extra two miles an hour you'd have an
accident and that will be a worse
outcome than oh you went slightly above
the speed limit
so and it's it's hard to decide whether
you for example the question of should
an AI do what its owner tells it to do
you might very well say well for
societal reasons you want to pull back
from that maybe or you want to say maybe
you want to have as a sort of primary
objective that it's always humans in
charge in which case yeah you should
make the AI do whatever it's human owner
tells it to do of course it gets more
ornate when you have a an AI toy for a
cat and you say does it always do what
the cat tells it to do well then then
you're in another whole complicated Loop
of um uh you know the the um uh but but
the question of sort of what are the
provisions what are the kind of elements
of what one can think of as sort of an
AI Constitution what do you put in there
to say you want the AI to do this you
don't want the AI to do that one of the
things that's very bizarre in today's
world is that and today's I mean last
few months is that you give these
textual prompts that say what you want
the AI to do and you're literally
writing something that looks very much
like a piece of legal a legal document
that says do this don't do this Etc et
cetera et cetera and um
I think that's a something I was not
anticipating I think to some extent at
some level people find that a bit
unsatisfactory because they'll say what
does it really mean well of course
they've said that about the US
constitutional laws or whatever else
forever you know what is the
interpretation of these words
well that's where people when they can
turn them into computational language
where there is a well-defined meaning
that is defined by what the thing does
when it runs as a computation
um there will be a desire to do that in
a bunch of cases but this whole question
about uh you know how do you get the AIS
to quotes do what we want depends what
what it means to do what we want it
depends how globally you have to have
people agree about what things whether
whether they all whether all the AIS
need to be pointed in the same direction
it's the thing I think I mentioned this
another time about you know does
everybody drive on the same side of the
road
um you know you can't have at least in a
simple way of setting things up you
can't have some people driving on one
side of the road some people driving on
the other side of the road
um and uh you know because then the cars
crash into each other of course if the
cars were smart enough and were
self-driving enough they'd be able to
dodge each other and you could have a
much less sort of rigorously defined
it's the left drivers and the right
drivers type thing
um I think that the um uh you don't then
have to have as much in that particular
case sort of AI itself saves you from
having to have as much sort of global
alignment between what the different AIS
are doing
um that in that case but there are
certainly cases where you know we share
the space
um and other resources of the world so
to speak and there are places where you
know you can't have uh one thing you
know I don't know doing I don't know
what they might do you know generating a
huge noise and then somebody right next
door is like trying to sleep or whatever
else
um that that's you know that's going to
lead to unhappiness just because you
could say well let's again you can you
can sort of solve it with technology
let's have this this phased array that
sort of noise canceling array that you
that the thing can put up so that
there's noise in one place and it only
affects those one set of people and you
know one house over uh it's perfectly
quiet because of this complicated you
know cancellation of of uh uh of of of
sound waves and things or something like
that but in you know there are plenty of
cases where there's sort of a collective
experience where you have to have sort
of an alignment there and that's that's
a tricky thing to achieve I mean I think
one of the things I was I was thinking
about is let's say you've got lots of
people they have lots of opinions about
things and you say well what's going to
happen in the world you know what what
should you do in the world well an
interesting sort of possibility is
everybody writes an essay everybody what
writes what amounts to a prompt for an
llm and you just feed them all into the
alarm you say here's 10 000 prompts that
came from all the people who live in
this particular part of a city or
something and um okay llm should we
build a park here or not and the llm is
is just has ingested all of these essays
by people some people saying you know I
really want to find kite some people
saying I really want to have a road that
gets faster from here to there all those
kinds of things and it would be
interesting to know
um is that a form of is that a sort of
post-democracy form of government to say
um you know just everybody write an
essay so to speak rather than people
saying I vote for so and so to be
representing me or whatever else I don't
know I think it's an interesting sort of
thought experiment and possibility
um and uh it's something that um you
know is a but as we start talking about
the the question of whether the AIS are
going to do what we want it's who's the
we and how do we decide what we want so
to speak and that's a tricky thing now
uh you know as I say the one thing we
probably most agree on is AIS don't make
us go extinct
um I think that's a a tricky thing to I
mean I I would say that that um I I tend
to think we're pretty far away from a
situation where the AIS could have any
chance of making us go extinct
um and uh but it will be the case that
AIS will be increasingly hooked up to
critical systems in the world and uh but
I think it's probably the case that that
the kind of oh let's make the whole
species go extinct and one Fell Swoop is
not really a thing it's very hard to do
I mean it turns out it turns out we're
kind of there's lots of us and you know
eight billion of us or whatever and a
spread over a you know reasonable sized
planet and uh it's kind of like there
are very few things that are kind of
like globally oh yeah you press one
wrong button and the whole thing blows
up type thing I suppose the closest we
have is you know one can imagine some
terrible situation where where somebody
makes a designer virus that's just
really uh
um you know that that that's that's
terribly bad for all of us kills all of
us I think that's actually you know it's
surprisingly hard to do because usually
the more aggressive a virus is a virus
works by you know spreads from person to
person
um mostly
um and uh uh you know by the time it's a
really really deadly virus the person
will not be out and about infecting
other people if the virus has put them
totally out of action that's not always
the case there can be nasty things where
there's sort of a a delayed time type
thing where you get sick you you don't
know you're sick you infect a bunch of
other people and then the virus kind of
blows up on you but you know so things
like that could happen and I'm afraid
you know I I tend to think that the
nature of again for all sorts of reasons
about Immunology which let's not go into
here
um you know I think that's again a very
unlikely thing to be like wipe the whole
species out so I think in terms of you
know I don't think we're a heavy I don't
think we're heavy risk of Extinction so
to speak and the things below that uh
you know most of the things below that
it is not it is the case people will not
agree about you know where we should
make it do this not that we should make
it um uh you know it
um and then it becomes as messy as
things in the world typically are
um and you know some AIS will do this
eyes will do that
um and uh it'll be kind of like the way
it the way it is with people
um
let's see this very interesting
questions here what's it like to be an
llam asks Brady
well I don't know what's it like to be a
computer I was thinking about that
and even a traditional computer forget
all the AI stuff it's like you boot the
computer up you start it up
it sort of comes to life it's
interacting with the world it's you know
it has a camera it's watching stuff it's
waiting for people to type on its
keyboard
it's building up a certain amount of of
information in its memory a certain
amount of State for the computer and
then eventually you know after a week a
month whatever else the computer crashes
the operating system crashes with the
computer and it has to restart itself
and that process from from startup from
boot up to shutdown is kind of like a
human life it's kind of like you start
from a certain genetic template you
start from a certain set of things that
are stored on the computer then you sort
of come to life you record you remember
a bunch of things in your life and
eventually it's the end of your life and
then you know your your children sort of
uh are you know carry on or whatever and
they've started from similar genetic
material to yours it's just like kind of
the next boot cycle of your computer
it's kind of started From similar from a
similar uh point and in a sense the um
uh you know what you uh what you you
know if you if you're somebody who
writes down your thoughts or records
your thoughts or whatever in a sense
that's what's stored on the disk of the
computer and you know for the Next
Generation when the computer boots up
again that's what um that's what will be
visible there and I do think that the if
we imagine what it's sort of like to be
a computer it's actually surprisingly
similar to what it's like to be a human
you know there's things in the outside
world there's communication with other
computers all those kinds of things
um and uh it's um
uh it's it's surprisingly you know you
might think oh it's just a computer we
can look at it from the outside well you
know humans are just humans we can look
at them from the outside and and see
what they do in the case of a computer
we might know a little bit more about
how it works inside I think we're
beginning to know more about how brains
work inside we're beginning to know how
certainly idealized artificial brains of
neural Nets work
so I think the experience of being a
computer is is probably sort of the
inner experience of being a computer if
we can imagine that is is like the inner
experience is quite like the inner
experience of being human and of course
we only have our inner experience I have
my inner experience you all have your
inner experiences I can't know what your
inner experience is like I can I can
kind of see it from the outside I wish I
could see you guys more more uh more
explicitly here but um you know I can I
can see from the outside what you you
know what your characteristics and
behavior are that doesn't really tell me
it doesn't allow me to get inside and
experience you from inside you I can
only experience me from inside me and so
when we look at a computer we don't get
to experience the computer from inside
the computer maybe one day with neural
implants and things like this we'll get
a little bit closer to experience in the
computer from inside the computer but
we're not there yet
um
let's see
uh
question here there's several very
interesting questions there's a question
here about will will programmers become
obsolete yeah low-level programming is
going to become obsolete in the same way
that Assembly Language programming has
become obsolete became obsolete decades
ago now
I mean the you know you need to tell a
computer what to do and tell it what to
do in a precise way the language that
I've just spent the last few decades
building is a is the highest level way
that we have right now to tell computers
what we want them to do precisely and
that's you know that's something that's
going to continue to be useful but when
it's like oh and and let's tell the
computers in more detail of lower level
what to do you know that's automatable
I've known that's automatable for 40
years you know I've been in the process
of automating it and I've done a lot to
automate it in the last 40 years many
people have used what we what we've
built
um the fact that there are many people
writing kind of low-level programs is
sort of a strange anomaly of history I
mean I think perhaps it's a inadequacy
on my own part to have not managed to
explain to people more clearly although
I think I've done a fair amounts along
those lines
um you know how you can interact with
computers at a higher level there's
there's some there has been you know
continued interest no I should learn to
program and you know write this code and
learn about memory allocation and this
and that and the other you know those
are things which it's like you drive a
car yes it's amusing to know how spark
plugs work and how fuel injection works
and so on but most people who drive cars
do not need to understand fuel injection
um it's uh you know it's a different
level and the same is true of of uh of
computation except that people have had
the idea that you really do have to
understand the fuel injection as you did
you know when cars were young you know
you had to understand all kinds of
things about how they worked in order to
in order to use a car but then they got
more automated and don't have to do that
um
gosh there's a question here from assist
what are suggestions for a high school
student who is interested in both Ai and
physics
um
uh
come to our summer program that's a
that's a good very practical suggestion
um I think
that
the
uh it depends what kind of physics and
maybe this is I know I have to go in a
minute so I'm not going to have a chance
to give this question it's it's um uh
it's it's real um
best response I think one of the things
that kind of has come out of the physics
project we've done in the last three
years is physics is ultimately
computational we didn't know that before
we thought physics was mathematical but
it isn't it's computational as well as
mathematical
and so the things that come out of
understanding the concepts of
computation are really important now
very recent knowledge to understanding
physics and sort of there's an
increasing opportunity for people who
understand computation to contribute to
physics and to contribute to the
foundations of physical we're seeing
that in the you know a few hundred
people probably who are working on sort
of our approach to physics at this point
it's like you really have to understand
the computation side of things there's
some pieces you can do with sort of more
mathematical physics as well but but um
it's very useful to understand the
computational aspect of things
and that's a bit like what's to an AI
now you know one SEO about AI is there's
a lot of kind of engineering Plumbing
that has been traditionally done in AI I
don't know how much that's going to
continue
um but that's been
and it makes it much more like an
engineering field a much less like a
theoretical science field I think that
may emerge a theoretical science kind of
field in AI that hasn't really emerged
yet but uh the thing you know it's kind
of like there has been in the past
there's engineering on the one side in
AI there's kind of mathematical type
science on the other side in physics now
both of these look more computational
now in the case of AI I would say the
the biggest question these days is Okay
so we've got these capabilities for AIS
how are we going to be able to use those
that's sort of more so than let's go and
understand more about the details of the
capabilities it's kind of how do we take
this building block and use it to uh to
make further progress
there's more to say about this maybe I
can cover it again
um
next next week
um but uh I think I have to wrap up now
because I've got to go and uh do some
day job work here
um but uh thanks for joining me and um
thanks for these interesting questions
it seems like we're in a in an AI in the
history of AI this was sort of this
period of the AI winter but it seemed
like nothing was going to work in AI I
think we're now in the uh AI mid-summer
day or something where um uh where it
seems like everything is working with AI
um and perhaps we can continue
um uh uh talking about AI but um uh next
week but thanks very much and bye for
now